الجزائر الان حيث تعرض تمثال المراه
العاريه الشهير بنافوره عين الفواره وسط
مدينه سطيف للتخريب مره اخرى عندما اقدم
شاب على محاوله تهديمه مساء امس قبل ان
يتدخل مواطنا لايقافه وسيله اعلم جزائريه
محليه نقلتنا الشاب الذي اعتقلته الشرطه
بعدها لم يكن في وعيه وكان في حاله سكر
وتعد هذه المره الثالثه التي يتعرض فيها
تمثال الى التخريب ففي اكتوبر من عام 2018
تعرضت امثاله الى محاوله تخريب جديده بعد
اقل من سنه على تعرضه الى تخريب من قبل
شخص قيل عنه انه مختل عقليا حينها
للمزيد ينضم الينا من الجزاء العاصمه
الصحفيه ومدير موقع رحبه نات سيد محمد
حاجي اهلا وسهلا بك بدايه ما الذي حدث في
سطيف السيد محمد حاجيه
الحادث وقع امس في حدود الساعه الثامنه
بتوقيت المحلي يبدو ان هناك
خلال مباراه الكاميرون
والبرازيل ويبدو انه توجه الى التمثال وهو
عليه
مثل ما ذكر الاعلام كان في حاله السكر
والاذى تتمثل حاليا في بعض العضلات في على
مستوى الثدي الايسر لهذا ال همم لهذه
المنحوته
طبعا همم ليست هذه المره الاولى التي تعرف
فيها تمثال لاعتداء حدث ذلك
عندما وضعت الجماع على الارهابيه همم
[موسيقى]
قنبله يدويه وحاول التفجير ال
ال المعلم الفني والاثري واتكرر ذلك في عن
96 ثم في عام 2006 ثم في عام 2017 2018
اعتقد ان سلسله الاعتداءات الاخيره يمكن
ايضا وضعها في السياق خطاب متطرف يدعو الى
ازاله التمثال بحجه انه يخرج الحياه العام
متى تعرف تمثال يمثل منحوته لما
هناك دعوات حتى من رجال الدين وتناقلتها
وسائل الاعلام في السنوات الماضيه دعت الى
ازاله انت
اج ولكن ايضا عندما ترى مثلا في الاخر
مرتين في 2017
عقليا في 2020 شخص شاب في العشرينيات وهمم
في حاله سكر يبدو انهما لا يمثلان يعني
الافكار
نفسها
الى المساله من منطلق غياب الثقافه المدن
الجزائريه
من حيث عدد السكان في الجزائر
قاعه سينما بدون مكتبات شكرا جزيلا لك سيد
محمد حاجي على مقاطع
من الجزائر العاصمه شكرا جزيلا لك